bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
vino sono poi c'è oggi siamo tornati su
minecraft ma un video speciale che vi
spiega lo stesso ne siamo divisi in
quattro team il team di nico il nostro
team quello di fa vj è quello di loro
insiste vedete facilmente chi fa parte
di ogni team è quest'oggi ci sederemo in
una caccia al tesoro che potete far
casino così tanto a dire ok va bene
quanti i neuroni in uno youtubers morti
tutti bene e devo leggere lei è sta roba
immagino ok se raggiungi la torre più
alta e osservatore da che la forma più
alta è quella quella abbiamo marciato
corri corri e tira giù divertiva a marzo
tiene un'associazione mafiosa comunque
no scusate ma scusami hp e ball però
scusa però scusami non è la tonnellata
mentre aspettava fatto qualcuno diceva
il messaggio no sono un messaggio devo
andare verso genera poi c'è scritto
nella tolta la torre più alta guarda
intorno
secondo me fuori raga non è dentro è ok
io sono qua fuori
no niente diceva c'è il sì ma c'è
scritto ragazzo ma che ricevo da questa
sera ci ha fatto quello che ci rimani
marcelo a caso ma residente in casa di
marci non ce la porta nascondo no è il
figlio salendo solo quello d'alema è
oramai tuo vecchio by two la lega qua
sembra più dietro però il discorso è che
siamo sicuri che 100.000 meraviglioso
aspettarci comunque questa roba che
ognuno ma che uno va su e gli altri sono
pronti ad andare subito sul indizio
ottima e prendeva almeno non siamo tra
minuto era importante però è mancato il
coraggio che se già non lo so non è
legge 104 100 ed i la ypsilon invece
l'altra
domanda quindi potrebbe essere in basso
la tessera che lo trovate inizio numero
2 l'ho preso c'ero solo io no glielo
posso rubare agli altri nove sono buone
le canne da zucchero vero cesca loro
sono buone le candele azzurre avvicina
il mio cane da zucchero lega fino al
mare su queste case le proposte sono
buone sono buone demaniali dall'edizione
dobbiamo togliere i visti agli altri non
abbiamo fatto le canne da zucchero
simone cosa vuol dire non la mangio io
le canne da zucchero e questo e non su
questi sono questo caso le credo
provenite ci sta non sono buone le canne
da zucchero che cacchio ne so che ama
bagnata la canna da zucchero ragazzi
invece numero 44 genova schipa come 4
manca un indizio ragazzi non hanno
trovato sotto qualsiasi vincente come
veniamo e come arrivo nel let her sta
arrivando ma ragazzi mi sembra esagerato
all'inizio non abbiamo fatto inizio 4 sa
bene cerchiamo le casse l'ultima inizio
vuoi trovare nella costruzione più alta
dovrei andare la via per il tesoro farai
brillare è quella di matisse secondo me
la costruzione più albero
chi è che al cosiddetto più alto marchio
matiz viola si siano abbassati
e quella di bianco e quella di fianco
quella gigantesca lì a sinistra vai vai
mark esatto io sto andando è molto più
alta di quella di marcia per forza
costruzione più alta
mannaggia a mano che non ce ne sia
ancora un'altra che non sappiamo ma
ragazzi non mi stanno picchiando vi
stanno picchiando perchè ci picchiano
perché perché vogliono è vista col arci
per andare lì vai malaga problema non
abbiamo i blocchi abbastanza perché
matiz è fatta tutta fulco bluestone ma
certo la scala della cia scala per ora
canalis magari socialista che si accende
ricchia lo picchiano dati ratifica non
ammazzo ammazzato preso all'inizio
utilizza 5 ha detto che non si poteva
fare ha aggiunto c'è una mappa tieni
prendi frascara proprio contando che non
è come l'avete la vedrà a vedere le
puntate l'ho buttata oddio aspettami
potuto presa era dell'ultima sapete no
vabbè a dobbiamo trovare che dobbiamo
trovare la casa è la casali staff e fer
e sono quasi sicuro perché c'è un lago
intorno ripetere aspettami vedo io che
mi muove c'è qualcuno che ci sta
arrivando vedo qualcuno che si sta
muovendo lì quindi sì ci stanno
arrivando e devi andare assolutamente
non so c'è una casa con un lago intorno
penso sia quasi stesse fare perché nella
roccia al di la di lei di baviera c'è un
lago intorno c'è un ponte che la collega
quindi non so se stesse fare con la dire
che noi è quella di che noi a me non è
questa regata e no perché il ponte la
collegava all'erba chi è che c'è una
base così nell'acqua scusatemi ma per
fare ciò nella vicina casa ma sta
scavando lì dove serve toccando le
guarda è vero era vero vero estetico
scavando è ma non è qui ma è sicuro che
non è poco
sta ma sicura 3.000 per cento secondo me
non può essere qua perché non c'è la
mano chi è che la mappa marco e mara
carina ma non si arriva rigori 3 mila
per cento che non è quella caverna raga
cosa diceva l'indizio devi scavare
qualche blocco c'è scritto aspetta però
stesso ha detto che se quella palla la
campagna alla pietra mi sembra non ci
dobbiamo arrivare a un certo punto come
ragazzi non è non è qua però boh
proviamo stato abbia mostrando i geni ma
non equa ma anche famiglie della valuta
è stato proprio io mi trovo dovremmo
andare perché se esse non scavando a
caso stiamo scavando nella perdizione
totalmente sbagliata stanno tutti qua
sta arrivando gente sta arrivando gente
attenzione è forse potrebbe essere in
qua perché stereo di un sacco di gente
che verrà scavata 40 dove può essere
giusta vai vai vai
intanto accettano come per la cesta
alberto sentite più attorno ai al suo
caschetto con mathis qualcosa qua o sul
blocco qua non vendo c'è il cda roma
scavata aspetta madame arcerito vediamo
e non lo vedo neanche sono in una
caverna io ho scritto qualche blocco noi
siamo dove diavolo è noi erano vicini si
affaccia una certa che non è questo ma
porca vacca
ecco la trovata cosa dov'era no
prevediamo vedere bambini sopra era solo
no però non da valori vediamo dicembre a
credere che sta uscendo e di dove
abbiamo meno ma dai ragazzi stanno bene
ma dai perché ma fammi vedere la mappa
scusa ma da e vabbè ma ti spiego sai
perché ti ha caricato perché vedi quel
ponte perché era il vecchio ponte che le
tesi per collegare non ci voglio credere
e vabbè ma era avvantaggiata che noi è
tutto sto casino capito ma ci ammazziamo
esiste con secondi a pari merito con
step non è male ei ragazzi questa
dall'episodio su minecraft spero vi sia
piaciuto perché storia di nel sacco
peccato non abbiamo vinto per un niente
ma edizione però ci faremo nel prossimo
perché ne organizzano tardi visto che mi
sono divertito tantissimo peccato a
creare tanto così porca vacca vedrai che
sia piaciuto iscritte anche a ragazzi e
ne come sempre ci vediamo
[Musica]